[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone and welcome to another
games for play for all charity stream
I'm Lucy James and today I'm joined by
the illustrious guys from kind of funny
illustrious okay that's that we've been
called worse we've been called worse for
sure hello Andy Cortese
good morning everybody and excope you
know
good morning it's midday in Hawaii in
Hawaii okay good
hey good morning everyone what you don't
understand about us Lucy is that we're a
hardcore streamers here okay we stream
our all night work right and Andy Andy
what time to go to bed last night or
have you gone to bed yet is it still
your night time I mean so les I want a
bit of 2:00 in the morning but the prior
nights only I was like 7 a.m. every day
terrible what what so when the Sun comes
up is that your cue to go to sleep like
a vampire you have to go like the Sun's
up I can't I have to sleep I was like I
left clothes in the dryer I gotta go
it's gonna be dark and I open the door
and it's just bright from the morning is
like Las Vegas Nevada where you don't
know what time it is Oh Nevada
thank you for spelling it out I wouldn't
have understood if you just left it all
you know there's actually a lot at Las
Vegas Florida of course there's got
nothing but Cove it'd know and I got
Cove it and they got knockoff towns all
right here's the problem here's the deal
I just made that up but you didn't know
you didn't know so that's why I clarify
because there's people that don't live
in America that have never heard of Las
Vegas we're like we're watching the
stream please educate us if you don't
live in America and you say Las Vegas
Las Vegas is world-famous you don't have
they're not thinking you're saying Las
Vegas Florida in its misery Tish I don't
know stuff you could be telling the
truth
I'm Hansard to and the chat says there
is no Las Vegas for picnic is that why I
want to see my hour Einstein impression
yeah I made ask Nick why he won't be
playing immediately with us today yeah
we wanted to do quads we want warzone
quads
and why are you playing Nick because I
didn't realize there was an update
required and now I'm 23 minutes have 23
minutes left of this 700 gigabyte file
that I'm downloading and I had to delete
a two games to do it and I think I might
have to delete a third I think at this
point call of duty just wants you to
like drop blood and put it on top of the
machine as well Jer that you can
download whatever the update is and Lucy
you were saying that it might be a
language file and to which I reply what
what is I mean I've only a me I'm ways
it the single-player that that would
need because right now all I hear is
Auntie yelling at me that I'm not good
enough and I think he can just do that
in English and it's totally fine I will
if it's cool of GE you just basically
have to assume that there is always an
update file yeah there's always a man
there's always a city if there's an
update I mean but this is egregious I'm
gonna say that I'm just saying this what
happened this wouldn't have happened if
Andy and Lucy would have been real
gamers in down to play Game of the Year
candidate predator hunting grounds do
you want to flip this way every time I
mention it in this house you just go I
got motion sick you skip oceans acquaint
and then you get won't play again I I
assume they fixed that but that first
time that we played it and on in general
release yeah I I did feel very sick and
I had to do a lie down it's good on you
almost made me motion sick yesterday so
you know maybe silence video game stuff
up you know yeah I like that you refer
to it as I had to do a lie down the
phrase I don't like I'm saying that from
now on because we would just say I had
to lie down but you said I had to do a
lie down we say we have to take a map
the thing is I'm just always scared
about introducing things into Nick sort
of everyday yeah I'm gonna do a lie down
I'll tell you what right now I just for
no reason to drink
this side of at IIT I kid you not this
much of it was sugar and my stomach so
upset that I think after this that's
exciting dream for this conversation
Tamaki same says he can join if we need
a full I tell him his services aren't
needed we need him in top predator shape
all right he needs to be in Pratt
mentorship everyone wants to play editor
except you Andy
the other day I set up a stream with
Jason musically three hours of predator
and you were belly aching about it come
on three hours of the hunt do a load of
laundry I gotta get in my 7:00 p.m. nap
so I can see the three 30 crew role on
the toy a lot of coal miners coming out
with the black lung they gotta have
something to watch Chalmers also said
the credit to Jasmine
that's too good you know any mean and do
you think it's a British thing yeah yeah
maybe man the red [ __ ] scream is
fighting a baby's face confusing
right right and II so like so originally
this is gonna be great because Nick's
terrible and I'm better than but now I'm
terrible and I'm the only one of the
group who's only played one match before
I'm gonna be on you I need you to tell
me where to go what to do and I will
take your orders do you see the yellow
icon the lumberyard over there yeah yeah
we're gonna drop our away wait lumber
yacht that's oh yeah we're dropping far
away we're gonna be safe out there I
can't wait for you to get to the Gulag
oh I saw him I had to do that I did one
you know to make sure I got through all
my things cuz I wanted to make sure my
game was updated and I've gone through
tutorials and everything I'm like things
I like sure saw that hard rock how
everybody um so just to say we're trying
to get our first wins
despite of me playing a little bit of
war zone
but also we're raising money that's
already really any rude are you getting
shot in the sky Greg yes okay oh I see
him I see him oh I'm coming to you Greg
I'm he's he's trying to fall on you I'm
landing right right told me to land you
your God there's people right where you
told me lame alright I'm on the roof but
there's people inside the building Andy
there's no moose I'm I am literally a
Cat on a Hot Tin Roof here I need you
right now
Oh see wasn't that good I got the one
guy sorry I'm expecting pro level call
it's my victory for the day but also
raising money links are on screen right
now Victor ly / gs-12 I'm dead I'm dead
okay
he's on your left on your left he's in
the middle he's in the middle he's gone
run right
good job man nice job yeah and what a
gamer okay
I'm gonna [ __ ] you you're gonna win Amy
I'm requesting a redeployment yeah I
gotta get money first glad to see me was
able to make it eight minutes into this
stream before ever the bathroom stop
down here loose together
Tammy we were so close to winning that
fight dude that first one my dreams
forever without if you just drop it Otto
puts the partially no but I uh I had
already put it out I was floating all
right and I just came a rush into the
ground I in the chat Jules Roble says
puts no mic mic in he'll get you the win
I have sad news no Mike Mike has retired
from video games whoa there's a guy in
here with this yeah you were squatting
yeah what's that all about
he's running around the side loose which
side you ping him I found him
virtual trick says what a legacy he's
left there was I mean when it started
and said you were squad leader and I was
wondering if that's not party leader
right it's still based off tits so
basing putting us into groups of people
who don't know if they're doing like me
right you're a server any skill based
matchmaking buddy Johnny Ace is join the
fray hey everyone thanks for having me
it's me John LA's Esquire maybe one just
flew in fresh off fresh off a boat blew
in for forestry very very happy about
this so Johnny our social team has not
been promoting this appearance no no I
mean I know I mean people just know one
day it's gonna show up it's more of a
feeling it's like the force you know but
you can actually if you took my blood
cells you can see how awesome I am with
the meta chlorine levels okay so it's
not like the force it's exactly before
yeah it was like yeah exactly
Gani said hey you wanna see my Albert
Einstein impression sure Wow no he just
told me he just told me that this was
happening today and I should
quote-unquote stop by if I could so I
said why not and then the other day we
were booked I was thinking about Oliver
Einstein and how all those all he
invented the cars and relativity and
stuff and it was like that's so cool and
I saw a picture of him we go like this I
was like smart guy
smart guys thinking like loose did you
not have to get out of the gulag or did
you get out of the gulag yeah let's buy
back me back guys
oh you guys don't find that first run
well Gregg suck it quick oh yeah Johnny
you must have seen a different thing
that's not exactly what happened what's
going on with this update that Nick got
boy
nick says anything things through often
and then it kind of blows the café's
Nick into the room by the way
no I don't hate it I didn't seem the
building I gave my parole I'll walk with
it
wife interesting Greg yeah see do we
have owed okay there's a second I like I
have what I call it I'm your eye in the
sky right now I can tell you what I see
alright I see your weapon for you over
here Greggy I'm come around do you want
to call in loadouts oh yeah absolutely
alright can you give me some money wait
oh wait no we don't have enough money
it's 10k Oh guys I'll tell you anything
I know if it's down to buying Greg back
or just throwing money into a fire I
would say like you're even out of you're
gonna get more enjoyment out of throwing
the money and it'll fire I'm here
where's this gun you're talking about
there was a purple ago what was the gun
you pinged yeah I'm get this green one
Greg on here's this purple and get that
purple okay great member will you play
predator and then you just get a gun you
don't have to worry about other guns
it's great yeah like it should be simple
way exactly plate editor with with
Donnie ace I played with Johnny s before
you okay gotcha cuz the other day cuz
the other day got you okay I've kind of
always forget I mix up Nick and Johnny
Ace quite often the problem Andy is that
we'll a your dog we're having up a
little
what can you come drop your money Greg
if you come over here I don't what
button is it Lucy huh Chester TV in chat
says ace what are your fourth of July
plans well I don't have any as of yet
the big plan of course was to show up
for this in support and we've met what's
playing right now I'm sorry boarding
right now but at some point I might I
might buy something legal fireworks if
you start to shoot them off of people as
they walk by the street oh I hate that
cheap now so super cheap and totally
well it's really acceptable just to be
letting off fireworks at war
specifically in San Francisco
depending on where you walk in what
street people either care a lot about
koban or not at all and so if you go by
any of the bars where people are now
congregating very close to each other
and screaming and smoking and drinking
it's like none of this ever happened
guys you just blink your eyes and say
we're in two years ago that's the thing
Johnny where you say all this but of
course you just flew in slash boated in
four Malta
like I think you should be currently in
quarantine not in Nick's house you know
Greg boats are easy to keep social
distancing on you six feet apart and
also when you're balling out like me I
had the whole upper form of the boat it
was me it was me the captain and the
first mate was cam Justin hanging out
Captain Stubing maybe why don't why
don't you only have 30 bullets where can
I get more bullets can I buy those is
that a micro transaction when I level up
do I get some bullets yeah here I could
drop you some time I see somebody I was
gonna get shot to death so doesn't
matter I just prefer to have more
bullets in them what about your other
gun it's a hand gun it's got 30 I got 30
in the round of this assault rifle did
you pick up a loadout
sure did I thought where are you guys at
how many teams are left right now when
should we just keep and hide so okay so
camping doesn't work the way you would
hope that it works here Greg because
teams often have UAVs where they can
seen you on the radar
gotcha teams often have heartbeat
sensors for their bus have a little
device and see where you're at you know
so it doesn't it's not as easy as it
would be in few camp you can't run your
normal strides to ground we just run
away from every one of them claim that
you did something good sure you actually
have to try and shoot someone today got
it you can go look for ammo for Greg if
we just keep moving up I think maybe in
listen to the baby in this room yeah
maybe maybe there Greg yeah it'll be a
little early
okay um said regarding Jane has messaged
me humble brag but he says if we win
he'll donate $100 who do this so - I'm
saying WOW rag did he talk to you don't
you work with him yeah okay talk to him
most days God I think I think is cool
about Lucy talk see you reg because I
mean I'm quarantine quarantine man oh
you have - it was what you're saying he
was accidentally Koren teamed with and
then it was like damn it I screwed
myself you screwed yourself out of real
friendship good time we got drunk and
did a puzzle on Saturday and then we
watched 90% of aliens but then we caught
tired
I thought aliens so this is the sequel
to alien or not are the whole alien
franchise we already we watched alien
the other night and now we started
aliens we were all tired and we have
been drinking a lot of white clothes
white cloth sneak up on you man
I mostly normally um do we want to go
for this bounty was only a minute left
Oh ch a season chat what up chastity boo
the milky stains which is one hell of a
username says you guys aren't gonna win
that's a terrible attitude to have a
milking things and be gross yeah it
reminds me of time that my buddy Scott
he didn't realize that someone had left
him one of those like high school size
cartons of milk in the back of his car
during the summer he came out like yeah
they left it there like on a Friday on a
Monday he came out and the smell was
crying uh you could smell from a solid
15 feet away from the car it was so
disgusting and you could never I don't
know if you know anything about spoiled
milk smell in the heat of Southern
California but you can never get that
out I'm pretty sure that car still
smells like that that was like 20 years
ago in a college
we'd always get a pretzel
you know those colonies dipping sauce
yeah every game for the entire season I
would hide it under my friend sets but
we sit down in it
ahead and get so mad at me but everybody
thought was just the funniest thing so I
just kept doing it in there he might say
man that seemed like that Frank would
get stale let me tell you I kept it
interesting he never knew what it was
gonna happen he would think it was about
to happen it wouldn't happen anyone he
was just sitting it Greg I love how I
love how cheesy your sense of humor
thank you Wow
you really had your friend tied in a
knot there pretzels like a pretzel yeah
was your friend
salty Greg about that I'm crushing it
today guys you ever heard of print
Michaels
Brett no that's why we can't help you on
that one Andy that's too far I'm sorry
that's the one and the I'm gonna need
you to open up a different bag a jokes
pretzels Oh are we getting an ATV yeah
let's just drive somewhere all right
like it'll definitely alert the whole
server as to where we're at but I feel
like it's a safe call yeah oh wait I
need you up on top you can jump on top
okay yeah no no you can like just like
oh very good
we don't need wide is gonna figure
yeah you too cuz you're cheating this
well in the chat says Greg he's an
armored up so hold trial break all the
people hiding here oh [ __ ] am I the only
one on it
Jesus Christ oh okay I downed again
another guy true says the ASA stream
quality is great all the way from Malta
oh no sorry drew I actually I'm coming I
came to visit San Francisco because I
heard y'all had a problem here with
kovat and I came to make sure everyone's
social distances and and make sure that
that's it and we're just right now since
I got here apparently the kovetz been
down that's that's dangerously false
news thank you thank you ma'am I don't
know I personally have done it I just
thought my inspiration has made the boy
safer we all love it it's okay I mean
you could come save me like I see you
over there
yeah come on my second match of all time
my first time here was with the with the
mates
ELC says the ace is really carrying this
team mentally I feel great about all
this you're gonna get back going oh yeah
eight minutes left ladies and gentlemen
it's now uh but don't forget guys we
still have to install it cuz that's
always a fun part of this that's who
knows how long I could take that could
take five minutes that could take thirty
seven minutes and that ladies and
gentlemen could require an update as
well I'll keep you updated on the
situation like this back to you Lucy
please keep us updated on the update
thanks Johnny oh and by the way Johnny
back to you back to you Andy Andy
remember what I invited donut because
that was the Belgian make that a joke
that nick said earlier I invented shaggy
dogs okay so there is an operator called
gasps which I am really tempted to buy
but okay how you're always saying geezer
right no jeez oh yeah dude's got the
accent right uh well a lot of them do
cuz um we've got what Captain Price
Justin price here yeah
I mean Greg reading should be as the
British person oh my god so much it
really just cuts to the core of you huh
I mean it's it is see Amir Amir he'll
die to your face British folk its
simultaneously it's just insulting on
multiple levels one culturally
insensitive - it's an assault to your
ears and highest truth be told because
when he does it his face contorts and
just Johnny where's Malta Malta is in
the Gulf of a warm place from here it's
kind of near its you know yeah great
have you heard of France a half you know
where Frances it's not near who's all up
you know what I'm talking about multi of
the day Greg because Johnny Ace only
ever talks about Malta and I was
wondering if you knew where Malta was
because of course you're here with three
dumb Americans so like we don't know if
it ain't happenin here within the
continental 48 we don't know what's
happening the milky oh the milky stain
says dude that using it I says you gonna
edit your loadouts Greg oh yeah
so hit could be old all one go into
weapons loadout and then change to do I
don't want to be that I don't know if
we'll have time now that's the thing we
were playing the other night with Nick
scarpino John you know you know Nick
right yeah i'm very well acquainted with
that okay the other night with him and
it was it was one of those things lucy
where we got scared to introduced a new
aspect of the game towards it because
it's it's you know be kind of
complicated you know to show hey Greg
here's just loadout yeah I've played a
first person shooter though I know what
loadout are and II like that's you know
yeah I told me confusing it's just I
just want to warn you you know we've got
a couple donations in so Becca $5
anonymous
maybe the hacktivist group maybe just
hip-hop enough
maybe milky stays like let's no no never
let's never say milky stains ever again
this is never said it should be banned
from torture really good advice in the
chat so I'm gonna give a [ __ ] I'm gonna
give up I'm out that person in the chat
I'm just gonna type into this chat that
I'm in timeout until the fights not
displaying your full username finchy the
slug okay so I'm not be cheap at me I
gave somebody adult fifty and says Greg
Miller trending game that's right don't
forget so if you'd like to donate
towards black lives matter or covert
relief efforts across the world please
use the links in the description or on
screen now
right now thank you look there's a great
causes Thank You Johnny did you say we
were on the side look of it it's gonna
be easy but yeah we're gonna get there -
I've almost cured a year but the problem
is all those people from Arizona just
become cover and tainting the water so
I'm what I'm proposing right now is that
if you live in Arizona
stainer and let San Francisco be the one
true free city in all tomorrow
John you have a lie I got to see we have
a lot of extra funds being over such a
world traveler right and you have a
private jet you can go ever can you okay
with making like a five thousand dollar
donation right now right here right now
I'll make it if you match it in multis
don't have money
Andy listen beat when you beat Roger
Federer not once not twice but three
times changes at the Wimbledon man did I
say right mumble times when was that
really underrated kirsten dunst envision
movie man how good was that movie where
he's like why is this my career is over
but then her career starting and he has
to learn how to like and then they baby
for her father winner always like yeah
you don't I dedicate that to Tamar
Hussain uh Simon kadhi says less accents
more wins so he's probably eating his
words right now and I hope he's editing
that predator of you oh that predatory
review wait there's a guy on me where is
he I'm running gulag guys thanks for the
question guys yeah there's three minutes
left
oh my update thanks for asking Andy Oh
your update or is it a mix-up - yeah I
assume since listen let me ask you this
question Greg sure you have the
opportunity for greatness and there's a
controller right in front of you do you
care who started the update or do you
want to just take the range on it that
is a great point exactly
I don't care the system this is our nose
hotel I'm out right now any unique
sounds oh there's a team this team
behind you
I'm dead again okay well okay kids you
guys loved it followed me here
I should've dropped with Greg where it's
safe
Andy what's it like being the best
player on the team is it a terrible
burden no he's already been ahead yeah I
killed somebody loose
I went gulag came out dropped in a house
nobody was there and three people fought
me and the whole time I won't we [ __ ]
my teammate Greg you told me where to
drop by drop and then Lucy says a bad
drop don't drop yes that's not fair that
guy knew the map I saw the replay
I'm just saying um you know hi Kendall
and Jack where's it gone okay plan of
action is just go for glory right and if
you don't you die we all restart
somewhere I'll beckon lose I've
requested a redeployment yes I just need
some money
I requested redeployment loose okay I
would also I would also like to just
deploy for once yeah
I don't even want to redeploy I'm not
like green like Andy and I are I just
deploy matey feeling the ether wind
being prepped when were five minutes
from lunch and Nick scarpino sits down
he goes oh do I have to download season
four it would just what an [ __ ] right
I mean sorry it's our to use the a word
there but he just see it just seems like
he's so disrespectful to everyone's time
especially stream you know you think he
knows it's not our usual garbage it's so
cool that you got that that he let me be
here those that we could we could
actually make this stream interest and
fun entertaining you know yeah exactly
comedy I get some some hot struts I'm
alone and afraid
alright by station or you at were you
know money I've requested to be
redeployed yeah loops come to the admit
maybe can get this so Greg all around
the all around the map they're these
little things called
they're like little mini Mitch's that
think that I just ping for Lucy right
there
and it some of them whilst they're
called like scavenger missions so you
open boxes and they'll send like so
you'll send me to another scavenger box
and forth and you get more and more lewd
and it's really good and you get money
more importantly so you can bring back
bring back your mites you know yeah my
d-block one one one one says don't blame
Johnny for Nick's faults that's true
guys no it's a part of them I don't
think we're out of the fun we're in the
headband you know just gonna have to
take any responsibility for whatever
whatever you say your game before
yeah well it's cool cars over here
copying and now it's copying the update
file guys yeah that's the install now
that's the actual install great are you
sure this is going to though that final
four here so you'll know a pile of money
right there alright get this little
scavenger and we'll be good to go let's
see the awesome keV says John tell me
what are your thoughts on urban hiking
of the urban hiking trend that Greg is
creating question mark well I think it's
great that Greg's jumping on that
bandwagon and they created the urban the
urban hike but in Malta we call it
having an urban hike that's what we say
we're gonna take an urban hike so we're
gonna say okay I think I would wait for
Johnny used to take a hiker long time
Johnny let's come right over take a hike
say you take a height interface stuff
you know you know Johnny Johnny this
will sit in your little trash little
trash chute when you open up places you
write the netting everybody to you Lucy
don't worry they're busy like to play
this game
we just need five hundred dollars though
I know where is there is her are we
trying to hit a goal today for the
streamer we're just saying we're trying
to cure me here like I said I've already
kind of just I'm just gonna cure kovat
but every little bit helps
uh Eddie T king says Lucy the lone
leader
Andi the shooter Greg the tall guy with
a gun ace the spiritual support we're
the perfect all right is someone paying
okay by station yeah all right okay who
wants to come in first
Greg yeah bring me at first for sure
bringing Greg for sure yeah okay okay
there's some spice off to the right oh
you can't do the apex slide no I mean
you can Lucy but it's not anywhere is
good
all right Greg drop on me yeah oh oh
they're waiting I can't say no
no ultra dead now we're watching Oh
dropping that loadout Greg get that load
out you'll be good to go baby just yeah
just I mean if I cut it when I fall in
doc I think I have a malfunction I think
something's wrong with my parachute
they're like oh my god that guy oh
there's a game whenever a loadout drops
for just a general loadout happens the
more boxes there are the more people
there are around it
oh so it's just that's like a visual
clue to let you know gotcha [ __ ] popped
and you're like oh [ __ ] this is a
petawatt err you told me to drop Annika
you know anything that's on you I mean
you gotta you gotta risk it seems like
information I should have known before
cuz I was gonna not drop on it I was
gonna drop it high so four links on the
screen right now and also in the
description please donate where you are
raising money for two really great
causes
so for Direct Relief who provide
frontline health care workers who are
battling the covert 19 response just
like Johnny Ace here they're providing
protective clothing and support twenty
dollars from game jumper thank you thank
you game jumper up game jumper X cuz I'm
a huge Anna put your money where your
mouth is let's cure some stuff we're
also raising money for black lives
matter
Mike Milano gave $40 thank you so much
Raul Quintero $25 Steven Pina jr. $25
david moats $50 thank you so much Maps
Ally $25 and Mark Lewis $5 thank you so
much everyone
please keep donating and hopefully we'll
get we'll get a damn win guys cuz then
if we do tom has to donate hundred
dollars once we get any in here we're
gonna take one for sure go to loadout
Greg go to I'm trying to see your screen
Lucy the the question is though what it
what constitutes a win
right because I would say that's four
best friends hanging out playing a cool
video game just trying to raise the
money for charity is a win that's a win
as far as I'm concerned perk number two
great overkill but also I would say win
coming first you know that's what that
is like the technical definition of a
win but also I would say a win is that
when this install of this thing that's
already taken 20 minutes is that 36
percent and it just went to 37 percent
and I feel great about my chances of
being able to play one game with you
guys before 2 o'clock in the afternoon
so what I would do great okay that's
fine great yeah so over Colette's you do
two primary weapons an LMG and an m4 not
bad not bad then as you keep on leveling
things these weapons up you see us as
level 1 on the bottom of it yeah they
really say rip this off from predator
hunting grounds Oh interesting
yeah chicken or eggs you're taking so
long you can install the entire adobe
suite by now well you know I think ace I
think you know maybe you have one person
to blame you know you Nick's car peanuts
well I mean I'll blame Nick for it I
don't mind I'll throw his ass under the
bus any day every week twice on Sundays
oh yeah all right
a party bundle the last prophet 11 says
someone tell Greg to buy a gun from the
shop great buy a gun from the shop no I
like the guns I have I'm not gonna give
this microtransaction BS you know to me
I understand man microtransactions are
the death of gaming in my day you had to
earn everything and it all came on the
disk
my day they just gave you a gun he went
out and killed Oh lunch a brownie it's a
great name subscribe for three months
that's a one month stream cool sprays on
okay we're gonna be totally fine I like
Greg just kind of he's feeling the flow
into the rhythm of doing I feel yeah we
do these little recon op operations will
be fun uh big Khalif says
he'll donate 50 bucks if Gregg can get
two more kills okay Wow so like
throughout the entire thing not just in
this match I think throughout the entire
yeah throughout the entire on the
monetary donation please that's huge
red lights April 30 disgrace got this
he's got this my god you got this Greg
Greg's gotten used to growl I mean look
here's the thing me and stole Mike Mike
and the dirty boys we've been often
talking about the growl weapon that is
often used and called duty right now and
I think that the m4 is the way to go
Greg's got the m4 he's primed for a
victory I'm gonna the stadium over here
guys
okay
oh my love these lobbies I love these
lobbies so far just got three of them
milky stain says fifty bucks if you get
to top ten so top ten
that's all goal top ten that's not well
start dropping in hasta the m4 mp5 is
the wars in class with it so i'm i think
i'm using a i like a sniper as my
secondary but i have a load out please
see called a fully loaded loadout thank
you you call them better they call well
that's where uh so there's a perk direct
and you can put on the gun where as soon
as the gun spawns it gives you full ammo
all the way and so I like you see it for
later so when you drop you like worried
about by finding I've said during the
entire stream got it 50 bucks to each
charity if Greg can get two more kills
you got hewed I'm gonna get it right
here I'm gonna get him here back to back
don't worry Greg no pressure and the
snow bike bike and the jet voice visited
a Prius lately it's a
Johnny Ace knows that movie right with
Mark Wahlberg and Will Ferrell what you
daddy's your attendance the other guys
oh I haven't watched the other guys it's
queued up on Nick's Netflix queue so
just take it and watch it Rick you guys
show you casserole you know what's on
his Netflix we do share a bathroom
yeah oh my god there's so many people
here guys what's funny is Apple said a
real problem
Johnny no wait oh now I understand why
don't you figure that big done oh I was
I know don't worry it's stupid I
understand now the importance of that
Lodi box that gets me to load out I said
good job Greg okay he with every shot I
got a gulag when does that count as a
kill that's a killer it is a killer
break Johnny why don't you want money to
go to charity I won't let you go charity
but I want you also to get off your ass
real kill for once are you guys dead
where are you guys when you come back
I'm landing at the red top building all
right I'm coming with you Greg sometimes
if you if you're in the gulag for long
enough and they don't find you a match
you just win by default
Greg that counts two best words that
counts 20 make an all-beef what maybe
I'm here don't worry hey Greg ah
hey Greg here let me drop your weapon
it's a burst weapon be kind of mine how
the [ __ ] do I drop this thing there we
go no that's actually on automatically
when I job that's what I like I like I
don't like I don't like I don't like
first and unfortunately other character
has in Texas flag on its chest and
you're from Texas so I got him dude do
they have one with the Illinois wagon I
don't think so what is that just a
deep-dish pizza lots of guns in here
Greg the amount x equal x says Oh No
okay completely kill the guy up here
careful girl yeah where are the rest of
them where the rest of them right here
obi-wan jabroni 97 says just donated
yeah that is awesome guys it's like
we've been hired today read out some
donations in between Oreos help me oh
you want me to help you
oh just everyone I'm okay got out but
I'll just read the ones that people post
in here and take a little you better
they did it thank you yeah I can't give
you the the login cuz it has like
people's emails and stuff just say it
say it just say it over the air what the
what the login a password on people just
everyone be cool yeah I mean if we can
get if we can get Nick's Netflix to I
mean that's one less subscription for me
to have to pay for so what I really like
to do is just have Andy describe me beat
for beat the other guys the movie just
start from the top Andy and just make
sure you if I don't laugh at a Will
Ferrell joke do it five more times like
Nick okay okay oh so there's a midseason
update apparently in 11 hours time so
good job good job you updated down right
there a good gun right there
so wait I have to do this again in 11
hours it's taken two hours to do this
that's four hours of my life to play
this game this is yeah I'm halfway if
you asked of us I should just go back to
that you guys care if I play Last of Us
right now I gotta spoil anything Andy
what have I ever spoiled anything for
you every in review episode during
future spoilers mode when we say don't
don't do future spoilers an emu yeah but
like who doesn't know those spoilers who
does it know there's a people watching
the movie for the first time with us
next spider waiting you know I was
talking about the comments who doesn't
know that what do you think golems gonna
do just to bring a track on him where he
plays disco music until they go insane
now and big Lucy come back alright this
is a green this is outrageous how long
this thing takes to go
granny's a time screaming it's
installing the game right now why could
it possibly be taking so long it's 32
gigs really good weapon they're being
hunted Luke being hunted me stay away
from you loose you're you're damaged
goods now don't Lucy do not listen to
him
stay on his six I've been pinging I'm
coming right now to get the gun even
thing yeah I think once we get cheeto
fingers back in here
or Johnny eight should I go get him can
i play this is the counter do I need to
go get him maybe we promoted it as
cheeto fingers I think so might be
helpful
you can just you can just tell me and
I'll have a wood we can get that promo
fixed Oh
oh that was really no when he comes back
now reminded promo image actually showed
you to show Johnny Ace and then we'll
hide and we'll go make him change again
who should there's people outside
apparently I see red lips on the door
they know we're here
yeah we're the hunted one guys these are
steer tactics don't buckle oh shoot they
are on the roof I'm gonna die what do we
do
you're gonna come hear me come pick me
up where are you on the second story
okay you're right above me I can't no no
I'm like safe I'm covering up Oh gas
mask is please um okay yeah we are
hunted Lucy we have a lair yeah well
protect me please they hate us because
they ain't us don't worry I got a dude I
put a claymore down I'd like I fully
killed one of them so they might back
off and be scared I mean the bounty is
only good for 30 seconds grab a gas mask
I think that guy's run away you may have
done it go get his friend at the Bison
i-19 maybe oh do want to UAV I can put
that over now yeah yeah oh yeah they are
all downstairs am i safe oh they are
above us they are there I mean we're not
safe they're still on us but they won't
get all the rewards for hunting us Oh
flash unlocked huh they're running away
they are running away I mean I want to
go hunt okay cuz this guy's downstairs
Thank You Richie
there is no friendly fire let's go those
are guys just hiding here okay
good weapons good good good jump on the
window
[Music]
we have a lot of money we have a lot of
money yeah we didn't get a load out
mm-hmm picking up that scavenger um I'd
say we can load out first everybody drop
your money oh hey guys what I meant
oh hey Nick you're back what's going on
Oh Johnny was here all right was it yeah
did he say anything cool about me no for
sure now cool my updates at 67% guys so
nice
oh it's actually theoretically possible
this point that it won't be finished
updating so we're done playing
[Applause]
I got a hit on that one public agent
that's two right there Joey
alright we're doing like dragon eating
we're getting you back immediately
Michael stop down and immediately
straight back down sure
baby
here Lizzy kitten do you have one of
these like homeless husband yes I'm bad
guys don't think I'll buy your [ __ ]
again guys you know what Nick you don't
know what it's like out here in the
world oh nice you know what it's like
did you 9% you know how we said that
Chaplin was attainable
what do we give you Oh 20 Wow that was
like the longest battle for 24th that
was an intense battle for 24th place
[Music]
[Music]
it's Jen cooking something yeah it
smells good yeah
damn what are you cooking back there
leftover fried rice I was good
no I'll get it later no Lucy was just
commenting how good's well kimchi fried
rice everybody let me read out some
donations that we thought concert but so
the game sorry
max Gingold or gin gold $25 to black
lives matter
thank you Andres Cortez $25 Kendal
Hackney $25 Eric lui $25 random at least
20 bucks
Connor story $20 old two black as a old
spot as butter as well as Kevon Clifton
$10 tip to pipe thank you so much and on
the Direct Relief side we've got hang on
Anthony Guerrero 35 bucks wasted
bandwidth I think because it doesn't
display your whole name like what is
wasted bandwidth mm-hmm his name a lot
thank you very much $20 now Isaac well
$10 like you now as Thomas has been
donating a lot and in a lot of our
streets
none of us $20 is this peace and
blessings
risky biscuit 25 bucks Ronnie Pattinson
20 bolt 20 bolas dollars and bran max 20
bucks sincerely love what you all do and
happy to support good courses also Gregg
sucks your vacuum well yes just a
reality Greg it's just the reality we're
working to change that reality Greg but
right now you saw everyday we're working
hard to make sure you don't suck yeah
over in the kind of a battle cat why am
man g89 ass if it's too late to submit
PS I love you questions it is I've
already assembled the show today of
course we're doing a your reviews and
questions and theories about last that
was part two you get that tomorrow
podcast service around the globe
youtube.com slash kind of funny games
and then game Jumper X did say earlier
Andy you've got to teach Greg about body
armor I know hold triangle you get three
segments I understand it I'm more in the
thing I'm just you know trying to figure
out the rest of it right now but I
understand it yeah that's one of the
things Greg's where if that's more of a
muscle memory thing yeah like it's so
there's so many times during when I
first started playing this game that I
would just forget and go into battles
with one and a half armor without always
reloads it's just like another thing to
reload for me okay I'm gonna go to this
roof
oh oh oh come on I'll tell you what
though these games have been bringing my
KDF everybody we've been getting extra
fat ratio eye candy and that's the most
important thing it's not the pigment
Gregg though how about that for charity
in I did get the kill for charity
did you kill okay I was watching later
when I got killed before didn't I kill
that guy in the gulag yeah no no the
gulag and then I shot one guy dead and
his other guy got me I may die just down
the other guy it definitely had the game
over Greggy
and then the guy's name over here
believed to judge okay
that price he got to he got to okay so
someone has to donate their clothes
Andy give us $50 I already 2225 and fit
well buddy friend Johnny Ace you can see
him in your house or Andy now is not the
time to be cheap
open up your pockets open up your hearts
come on Andy's got to he's like a cow oh
we jumping over that yeah oh come on
under Hugh's been squatter you know
every single time higher level right is
that what it is I don't know it probably
could just sense he knows more about the
key
yeah
and I gotta say really turn there you go
look I gotta - I was so happy when you
re watching that Lucy with Greg engine
it's like well you are watched it since
I'm really sad I keep bringing it up
well I'm glad that Greg understood the
jokes I love back in the day you guys
got some other guys coming in on you too
buddy thank you thank you for admitting
facts great we're just trying to make
you better listen I know you're all mad
that I'm so much better at predator than
you all right you predator it's not is
that shocking there Lucy that Greg is
secretly great at being a maniacal
killing machine that just just loves to
watch his friends suffer like that isn't
that just kind of Greg in a nutshell hi
how did I get that she'll I'm Greg grew
up here a lot of people to chat calling
for us to play plunder by the way that
old pirate game on PSN for ps3 no no and
I'd dig out my ps3 for the stream I
think yes threes in my room no that's
not anemic country oh oh oh I'm getting
shot oh okay thank you for the save here
I didn't know he was down there what you
think I just [ __ ] stubbed my toe and
died well I thought you would have said
he's in the next room a communicate
there Greg like you know shut up Nick
show me your Albert Einstein impression
again
okay okay punch punch the if you punch
music gets ready for 500 he's on your
thanks yeah baby this is like the judges
weak stuff for modern warfare and they
did this the one-on-one missions you
know any mean wherever they're called
right I'm sorry two on two missions come
back on the straight immediately down I
forgot about it
come back come back is there I'm right
I'm landing right on you Andy
yeah no let's just stand here Greg give
him the old Nitro rifle shuffle as I
call it give them the rifle film the
rifle along Andy do all that Andy do
everything in this set you and I are
related Greg I mean just by the
sister-wives relationship yeah just
that's not what sister wives are what's
the sister work
it's a show on TLC where they're all
Dale they're all polygamy and they're
all married to that one guy with the
hair he looks like Thorntons the more
it's a Mormon thing right isn't built
that wasn't Bill Paxton one of them
didn't you do a more mature like that um
Big Love yeah
that's it was weird it was good it was
weird I was thinking sister wives are
the Traveling Pants Andy would you
believe that I saw Sisterhood of the
Traveling Pants in the movie theater and
when I walked out I was like that's a
good movie those people but it's good
movie good to know yeah see Andy I do
have a heart
yeah Andy Oh someone I couldn't tell
where that came from
no guys the way no I mounted my weapon
so I'm pretty cool good job Greg good
job Greg I don't see the guy who came
over
just just oh I'm gonna die Greg tonight
I need you over here all the cough so I
got uh I got two of them I got one of
them other guy on the ground they
finished your work
there was definitely another team
pulling in anyway hey we're getting
there
you know we're learning 42nd place how
like we saw I don't pretty good
well now we're leveling up we'll get
people you know that are also pretty
good where I'm trouble that way you know
yeah you're just warming up guys just
warming up until till I can jump in the
game what's going on with you where you
at right now
here 90% guys we're swappable jump in
this game and pretend like I didn't make
this massive mistake ever again I will
deny this I won't die it I don't care
we got a few donations in so Anthony
again tilta Phi is a great service but
sometimes it cuts up people's usernames
and I can't see what your surname is but
Anthony gave $20 please let me know in
YouTube chat I'll give you the shoutout
Mac Hawking another familiar face $10 is
now a good time for me taking like 4 to
get Portillo on cameo show us I think
he's a great idea show us the kids gotta
be back there somewhere
bring us our can't be sleeping he's
sleeping do not disturb they can't gonna
wake the King you know I mean before the
show's over we'll get Porto back on this
uh and Khalif wannabe podcast $50 for
Greg remember it's not how many people
you don't exclude you it's the people
you t-bag along the way gotcha
it's true I've heard that a lot Nick
what is your percentage right thank you
my percentage is 92% of you guys have
one more one more without you let me
read out some black lives matter
donation so did I do
I think I said Chiron Clifton $10
Freddie Frederick's $25 thank you very
much
Nate Fletcher technologies and Cleef
items respond owe me $50 thank you very
much relief and thank you very much
everyone who's been donating links are
on screen and also in the description if
you would like to donate to some very
good causes
two people telling Greg to change the
radar from a circle to ask where we're
baby steps guys all right baby steps
that Russia yet you know I mean right
now it is very much about just getting a
feel for it getting guns out sun's out
exactly what you want
whenever you get Chad answer me this
when i unlock double xp or whatever in
the battle pass does that when does that
start does it start right when the match
starts or come on I've always been
confused by that YouTube also by the way
make check it out damn you look Mike
look at it looks nice now are you happy
with this cuz you've had some Mike
troubles over the last two months where
you just couldn't find one that worked
well not have up Yeti X and they was
giving me issues remember I was clipping
non-stop your groundless movie I know my
my game was always the lowest pop went
out stuff it but I got this and I love
it
I'm super glad for you know I like your
little your little boom setup there too
and I thing I've been thinking about
Greg's a little boom setup moose do you
have a boom setup as well or now boom on
your mic who me
yeah oh no I just have this little guy
the reason I got the blue Nick is
whenever I'm clicking on my keyboard or
moving my mouth it was always Bora and
now it's edible ice not a whole lot I
don't like
I don't like it
like Tim come on my man back fish it
starts straight away from the moment you
unlock it that's awful it should start
right when a match begins Bobby says
press f3 to see our tokens
I really enjoy ecology but this is too
many menus let's look for the top quarry
there's a lot of like recon so we can go
do over there
and if you have the pop filter to just
load up my wave yesterday I do yeah idea
percent guys oh my gosh he's all excited
about this graduated 1998 high school
it all comes full circle handy oh I
think you mean Nick Lachey graduating at
1088 probably he's probably my age as
well be actionable oh how old it's eerie
hey Siri hey Siri is Theory green it how
old is Nick Lachey I fully killed the
guy on top I accidentally dropped pretty
far away oh I just got down bye guys I'm
jumping into season 4 right now can't
tell you how excited I am
that's a big deal guys the big deal any
tips this is from Moises any tips her 21
year old who has started losing his
passion for gaming a constant to get
into any games anymore which is kind of
a bummer since I always looked forward
to the biggest thing I think I got to
force it I think everybody goes through
stuff they really like and then stuff
they don't like and then if you go there
you try to force playing games you're
not gonna find the game you want then I
just saw a little notification as if
Nick Scarpino started playing war zone
whoo
come on Greg I'm making my way - I know
those people around you I shot one and
he ran away scared and then now I'm
scared of him so I'm kind of just hiding
to feel like I could talk to him I could
push it up on him you know talk it out
pop it out pop it out uh tom says Siri
sounds like she's fully done with Nick's
question yeah she's done how often do
you speak - I speak in at least three
times per stream cuz I'll be talking
about like hey see and enjoy yes I'm
like I know it's not about you Cirie
it's not all about you yeah I try and
avoid the a word because otherwise
Alexis Alexa whatever it is yeah she
will be activated does great did a thing
where he's he's not there everybody
plays a song anyway just to spook you
guys out busy still do that uh he did
that with the Halloween theme a while
ago we thought you haven't done it in a
while oh you did do it on Saturday
because jenna and i really wanted to
listen to Saturday Night's Alright for
fighting but then we accidentally ended
up putting on what was it just some
weird song a very weird song and then
you left to go get us some white cloth
and then we put it on so we could enjoy
the song while you were doing that which
I very much appreciate see I'm a nice
guy yeah
they call it here you are a fledgling
show tell everybody I suck and then I
get a seat at all
we talk about okay we haven't said that
okay ffs in a while because my watch
last week's episode we had a great time
photoshopping ourselves in Photoshop to
make ourselves better looking dead
there's another kill for Greg put it on
the board
um Moises says I'm gonna go subscribe to
kind of funny I haven't seen Greg since
i gen days by the way thank you for the
advice on gaming huh
Thank You Moises remember youtube.com
slash kind of funny in youtube.com slash
kind of funny games there's nothing
gonna come an ad right all right guys
I'm ready so whenever you die or at
though Greg like I'll be here he was all
the way yeah where you are basically I
have a heartbeat sensor I can't see him
I to the beat of the drum Ke$ha remember
cash everybody
cash is great mission uh watching Greg's
gameplay got a pink so we can pitch Greg
how to have one I know I don't worry
about anything okay just wanted to know
where that guy listen well he's gone now
let's just get into the circle the
circle has got to be our problem here a
second to we have enough money to buy
back loose this guy we're gonna push I
kind of want to I feel like it's a guy
Greg I will be your eyes I will be
Oracle thank you good reference a good
reference thank you I'm just I'm
catering catering all my references oh
he's right above us he's right above us
Greg okay we're gonna do hey well played
I'm gonna rock at his ass sounds good to
me
now he's gone he's been he's running
away he's scared yeah huh what he got
loose I think I saw him like a flash of
a scope but maybe I imagined that man
this guy is slippery
we got the wall coming too don't forget
yeah yeah I would say get away from the
gas we're pretty much with gasps gasps
no gasps no no no in like the second
well wall you were supposed to yell
gasps gasps and it's meant to empty your
lungs so that when um ya didn't I don't
recall that but it sounds terrifying
hmm I mean I wasn't alive then but also
I think it was for the trenches so maybe
well one that makes it more six one four
one cuz he's a lot of mustard gas back
then but they did use guys and World War
two as well Oh correct him
nice all right we're gonna buy back Lucy
over here thank you
maybe buy me back you're not in the game
you a Cheeto back in the game gee did
you cheat Oh figures Oh me it's the guy
that you shot at
he's trying to get rid of it as usually
loud I have no ammo so I can't do much
for you got 21 shots me yeah you go
chats which are asking which is thank
you
no one else wherever Johnny hates goes
back to Malta
he is mercurial for sure you on the roof
or you insiders they're pushing yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah it is Lanka 1313 says
the ACE is probably just watching the
other guys right I guess why did he talk
about that nothing wants to do yeah
that's right
they made an omelet out of us you know
fun vasilia time said Lucy just uncover
herself like an immortal that's been
part of significant moments in history
Lucy are you a Highlander
so I haven't actually seen that show but
I hear that it's good yes she didn't
deny it
okay subterfuge I like that Keanu Reeves
painting yeah he is Dorian Gray here
would it surprise you guys to know that
I'm I didn't make my wife but I put on
Highlander the movie the original movie
from 1986 for her and she watched the
entire thing and actually kind of
enjoyed it and afterward we talked about
how immortality works in it and whether
or not they can two people one again
guys gulag winner over here in Spain
what I was born to do each other there
is a Highlander people there was quite a
few times I let me keep you chose action
well uh Highlander TV showing spin-offs
that I think we're not very successful
and they did a bunch of pilot or movies
as well but the movie came first in 1986
Gregg dramas shortly by the Navy show
which was good at alone okay and then
they made a Highlander to the quickening
and I know a lot of you were thinking
hey Nick how was that and yes it is
universally held as the worst movie
airplane and it is I tried watching that
again and I can I can attest to the fact
that it is pretty unwatchable
get that item as soon as you get it Greg
and you just how stay alive and if you
survive all of us come back alright so
get in here and get the item you tagged
upstairs yeah this thing yep and just
stay alive you got it Greg just run hide
but the thing is when you get that item
Greg everybody everybody can see so you
have three minutes to say I gotta say
like three minutes with this thing I
mean yeah alright ask a man commander is
that one with the Spaniard being played
by a Scotsman yes so the great thing
about Highlander Lucy is that the person
who played the Highlander who played a
Scottish Highlander was in fact French
and then the person who played the guy
his friend was a it was supposed to be
an Egyptian who had a Spanish name and
he was played by Sir Sean Connery
who is actually Scottish so that's why a
Highlander is so fun to watch because
you never know what you're gonna get you
never know what accent you're gonna get
Scottish with him and then French with
the other guy but it's confusing yeah we
watched my friends and I watched the
Scorpion King yesterday oh that's a sec
which I didn't realize doesn't really
line up with any mummy Canon doesn't
need ooh doesn't get the rock you got
the rocks biceps what else do you need
why do you need to make sense the rock
looks pretty skinny in it compared to
like usual rocks oh yeah well factor yes
oh god they're coming for you grab one I
believe they're coming for you so I want
you to know I got a hundred thirty bolts
with their names on it don't worry but
yeah Vince McMahon is an executive
producer on the Scorpion King oh that
was the thing back in the day if you
wanted a rock Dwayne the rock Johnson in
your movie if they use the word Rock and
Vince McMahon had to be a producer it's
sort of lonely Lorne Michaels was always
a producer on everything that came out
of SNL cuz he was like I like money and
I like money that's a great week in the
chat casino abala says screen sniped
you're right that's real that's the only
answer for how they're able to find and
shoot me through a wall like a bunch of
cowards for YouTube he wants to he wants
to sub youtube.com slash kind of funny
games come join us Nick can you join on
me all right we already got here week
guys can you hear me I'm in the party
let's go Oh Nick how much have you put
yeah me too
we blew it a lot for a couple nights in
a row I should I think and then I was
like dude I think I was like Greg I
think I made I think I got my audition I
think I nailed it makes no Mike Mike and
Andy and Kevin a sex are gonna hit me up
every night Mandy has ever talked to me
again
he's such a here's the thing Greg you
know how it is isn't it
you know inviting him is the most
difficult task of all time because he'll
say yes I'll say yeah yeah I'll try it
out and it just never happens cuz he's
gonna watch Bill and Ted for the 90th
time yeah no it's good you guys hit me
up at 10:30 at night you're like bro you
ready to go we'll be on it I mean
playing 30 minutes of predator with me
so that's what you text everybody about
predator like in 9:30 I feel like
everyone's been with her stuff by then
no here's here's real talking ID I do
want to play with you again but the last
time you text me I was actually hanging
out my wife and I was like well I should
put some time in here blood as I Drive
her insane so I will say that a Greg
you're right now we are partied up with
one of the best warzone players I've
ever seen or been a part of who's a NIC
scarpino cheeto fingers yeah has won 40
percent of his warzone matches played
and he has played 10 games and won four
times that is an absolute fact right
good Nick yeah how many are those your
snow bike Mike carrying the team me it's
come back Mike and Kevin a sex on the
same team of him sure but still super oh
that's that's crazy it's a crazy stack
it's cool and I'll tell you one thing
right now guys if you do anything to
jeopardize that stat right now I know
and you are I will never talk to you
again and I will egg your houses because
I know I'm loving all the cheeto fingers
emotes and chatter and then grow up
throw up the fingers every uh-huh
in games how people are saying that Greg
you've got done by cheetahs I know it it
it's cream cheese and it's embarrassing
to see that you know I thought the game
spot audience was cool
wait no no no biking chat Oh baby we're
going to the so Mike Mike here's the
deal
Khalif adam said i will donate 50
dollars towards these costs that
gamespot is doing right now it's good
for Koba 19 relief effort black lives
matter and Greg and me greg has like ten
kills already tonight
tons of blogging tonight yeah hey you
know I'm in the mood right now Jesus you
see me were withdrawn Andy's normally
talking about video games where we drop
in Andy call the ball I was still in a
black screen okay here we go
um let's see yeah I'd say Stadium what's
going hard let's go in hard no no no no
no let's go absolutely not let's go
Corey Oh crack Corey Corey it's been a
while guys so I apologize if I'm a
little rusty and by that I mean the best
of you why gonna suck
I mean here's the thing I'm ready wit
willing to say that Gregg's might be
better than Nick
oh he's 100% better than me how many
kills have you gotten already Greg have
you gotten killed in the game yeah I
don't like this narrative I mean I play
for a real game we know goddamn it I'm
down I'm down this guy just oh this guy
up on the see up on the roofers a bird I
can't tell
man that was violent what just happened
to me we both ran out of bullets we just
were hacking at each other with a bi bar
god there's one over here and I was like
I'll make you maybe we cool I'm in the
gulag everyone Andy right in there
there's the dude be careful kid all
right there's also that guy in the
building that Nick got killed in oh cars
coming on this job I'm back baby
goddamn babies jump daddy's back where
we have a where we asked you guys on
that green thank you yeah I require no
what are you go Greg
he's right there he's not the attack on
my lifetime and he's running around the
other side he's weak
Greg yeah it's just one guy it's just
one guy over here over here very ACWA
hit the dirt path over there I'm here
I'm here I'm here at loose fall back
fall back there I got oh my god I gotta
come back here come my girl let's go get
one i single-handedly take all of us I
need a better gun does anyone have one
they can spare I just have I am in
desperate need of armor plates yeah damn
hey guys we persevere that's what it's
all about
oh I'm played yes Greg has like three
revives already klutz resin mm-hmm I'm
happy for you great they don't call me
resi resogun for nothing you know they
call you resi resogun you resogun and I
wrestle guns the video game stuff they
say resi resogun people understand Oh
PlayStation 4 well you know Vita it was
on a bunch stuff
but their game coddies just called us a
beautiful mess we are we are happening
is you're watching it legends are being
foreign always happening watching it's
not always pretty good why are we spread
out so far I was I was gonna go for the
contract oh yeah let's do that let's do
that I was going that self is light
enough okay
where are you guys look at the look at
the radar Northwest what's happening
okay there's a guy in there I want to
just push him oh [ __ ] oh no that Oh
pulse water is the wide guard your squad
a lot going on down there I'm going good
luck lot in that window you're on a dead
you're on you're on a suicide mission I
can't be part of it wait can you play as
a woman in this game yet there's a in
real life god damn it I'm down okay okay
Nick come to me oh he's coming okay
killing this man let me get in the gulag
Adam yeah I got Clementi in Colombia
okay if you just executed me snow bike
bike Greg out here shoot the man from
mile a half away I love it they're not
good can I do that am I supposed to do
that I just like you know damaged fall
office I broke his armor oh is that good
does that make you happy dad well he's
just gonna put his armor back on not if
I get him in the head a third member of
our team would have backed me loose yep
as we were getting demolished there I
said very clearly and for the record
this is a suicide mission I'm leaving
you guys lone wolf in his lone wolf was
not approved by the committee and you
know it's not a tyranny here Greg and
you know contrary to your popular belief
we vote on Greg just run away yeah he's
definitely run are you [ __ ] kidding
it was a dead man's mission I'm sorry I
have a family to think about in this
universe I'm gonna sit here in this
universe you're a lone wolf
yeah are we all just gonna leave watch
Craig as he ran over by oh I'm gonna do
this I have the power to more Hussein
watching me I can do this just so you
know for future notes
Greg you'll if you see a team and they
don't see you you don't want to start
shooting immediately but I want to again
wanna like wait you don't know wait to
get closer and stuff because the odds
eat you're gonna kill one from that far
away aren't very happy I think you're
missing this so if I was doing I ended
up on the front page of Twitch wins and
ever he's like look how good he is you
know I don't know there's got to be an
opposite it's which fails isn't it it's
looks like that walls coming for the
wall I thought that building in time I
wanted just uh oh that good you know
what Greg maybe that guy over there that
just parachuted in maybe he's got some
fun so check it out it's a great call
Nicholas chambers says Greg's love for
the pistol blows my mind no I hate the
pistol I want off auto rifles but her
assault rifles but I just end up with 30
bolt at a time right between the top
it's gone now man that's gonna lay
backyard has dead to rights brother it's
all I gotta do it I had to try no listen
don't you want our team to win yeah I do
but I also worry at this point that you
won't you just purposely won't buy any
of us back hopefully annoying
everything's like the poor man's John
wick that just doesn't actually want to
fight that Harvey Rick I got you Greg
should forget everything I just said all
I think you're just talking about you
clear
the mechanism my screen says coach
anyone moments and out in your career
what want to that after graduating this
below go up go up go up go up I toss it
ready and I have a good luck usually me
if I spotted a grenade him there get out
sure any with three kills good shot
buddy that one man was just terrorizing
all over bus that guy I came into the
game and I was like hey guys let's go
[Laughter]
so coach Andy what would send out to you
as career-defining moves from your
teammates today what makes you proud to
have signed them it's a great question I
think a lot of it know before you
figured out it's got a team for Christ I
think I think a lot of it knowing that
we we signed cheeto fingers who has a
40% win percentage not anymore
unfortunately that's definitely gone
down pretty firm percentage Craig but
immediately there we have a winner's
mentality and with Lucy I've played
overwatch with her I know what she's
capable of I've seen her I've seen her
skills out in the battlefield Greg
Miller training gamer 2015 you know yes
it was half a decade ago yeah was at
this point a whole five years yeah but
he'll that's so something to hold on to
granny won't you want me a predator
right now see what happens one I don't
want so you want me one fireteam against
one brother that's gonna be okay sure
how about this how about just for the
sake of argument right yeah humor humor
me
check him look maybe me we stick
together and we just listen to what he
says I can't believe like I wasn't
paying attention cuz I was in the gulag
and like I know Lucy died I know Nick
died and I just got back to Greg and
like I guess Greg killed them all like
nope just peace that listen I'll tell
you what I saw from my perspective two
clowns on a hill pinned down they never
had shot shoot from a shot from a mile
away and alerted the guy over in white
and then they were just pinned down
behind some logs I have a chance to get
out find $300,000 revive everyone on one
of the
get a load out brought down and get a
cool car you know what I mean that's
that's what could have happened there
and we were close to that happening not
close that we were so far from that
happening that it's it felt like a
fantasy that's what it felt like I mean
most realities are fantasies until the
realities think about that what are you
saying Albert when one Albert Einstein
looked at the buggy and carriage and he
was like what if I motorized this do you
think that was his fantasy that he made
reality okay Jonathan sledge $50 to
black lives matter
Oscar Chara be a Chavarria each other
achieve Aria jeopardy yeah a hundred
bucks
Rover arts Matthew Santa Maria $25 Mike
Howard $50 snow bike Mike baby
let me tell you something right now snow
bike if you can hear my words we miss
you never have I missed your presence in
this game so much that I mean some would
say maybe it just takes a break for a
second we get some you're out your high
flying action with those helicopters
just putting it out there so Mike let's
get a helicopter by the way it's for
sure yeah I'm Michael Nelson 25 bills
snow bike I promise you you know you
know how I love how much I love playing
with you men and this gentleman sitting
above me cheeto fingers claims that we
that we curved him that we don't answer
his calls that we don't reach out well
first I just couldn't be any more
further from the truth
first that snow bikes never tax me he's
never called me as yet do you have his
number two do you guys have numbers we
do not we do not have snow like I'm I
hit you up all right bro how you knew
that without his number then yes Andy
first number in part doesn't have an e
be my but my go-between gotcha
PS n messages the thing Real Talk though
is this I don't like reaching out to
people who are way better at the game
because then they feel like oh we got to
play with Nick cause he's like you know
we feel sorry for carrying them down
that's the problem so I like to play
with you know
all myself more donations Oscar Ivan's
$100 with the message Gregg sucks
thank you very much please what you're
doing everybody think about who you're
leading and listening to suck it up
$25 for music II way to shoot the guy on
the ground instead of the threat Greg I
expect nothing less
I'm there I want the kill Frank don't
let anyone talk you out of this strategy
gameplay effect is never worked for you
in the past but you just do charity link
or Greg sucks
yeah and Moises who ya be there and he
helped him with his getting his passion
for gaming yet back guess five bucks and
says you guys are awesome I think I
found great new content huh is the y'all
new or Dear Abby not know I only knew
what tier IV was because we did a
charity segment with Josie Jie from Fire
Emblem and he called Dear Abby which is
a pun which I on Jesus correct
that was a really impressed do you
remember highlight hangs in the air the
doctor's office I subscribe to it
originally the fan art section I would
always submit fanarts
of just whatever not fan art you know
what I mean but yeah just because they
had a better section for like artists
alley kind of thing yeah highlight
magazine what sounds like a playboy or
no no it's a magazine for kids oh yeah
yeah it was just very positive I mean
teaching I live out all sorts of good
stuff
Nick when you were like probably 21 this
debuted and then when ad and I were
perfect kids like us were reading it and
like dr. Thomas it's it's funny great
because I'm Emery serves me correctly
you're closer in age to me than you are
to Andy yeah your memories are on a
night 180 held a shot stop shooting with
Yvonne that way oh you are close Greg
you're such a doll no I'm not he's 32 oh
I know you're right
anywhere we drop and call the ball Craig
little going over military base I listen
last time you can order I didn't listen
to me Greg it's not you it wouldn't a
matter of you listen to you said I'm
Lily I'm leaving you guys don't be with
me I'm going out on my own I said it's a
death trap to stay here and then you
guys send each out again maybe we'll
back up and then I was like oh I wish
someone would revive me and they Greg's
like up off shopping for groceries at
the local liquor store highlights
magazine debuted in the 40s whoa so
using highlights like a highlighter
right yes it's not like I lie like that
cool game that I don't read like South
American high lie is a cool looking game
it was my writing remember when jackass
played it when they just stood there I
last like the the game that like people
died in because it's still hardcore I do
not know what this game is but it's
terrifying there's a guy in this
building on yellow you ready cheeto come
on baby come on
go kill him oh we're right here
oh I need a better gonna get him happy
nail yeah good job Mandy he's executed
that dude he's a man without a team and
you killed him Hey Oh behind me OOP
somebody come raise me well I allow my
fellows go first
he's where Nick is
okay I that didn't work but I got one of
them nice shot eNOS oh great good luck
okay Nick I can spot for you so I was
bought from Nick's bar for me okay
he's well he's in the back
he's yeah yeah you see him he's in the
middle he's gone behind you behind you
he's on your left I got me
hammock I sorry I failed you for the
last time I'm not gonna swallow my
controller
no Nick except like I was surgical we
did it
thanks for the spot loose sorry I failed
you it's all right so they're gonna come
back down you that's dangerous Greg yes
there it is right there there's a guy
right great just let it go yeah who's
team good the guys were running away in
the farther it gets closer Greg just
fell out like Carol basket oh no just
like your first husband okay great get
that guy
nice Greg they're coming for you Greg
they come right behind you were you a
dandy are you dead too and we did we all
lose the gulag
no I won gulag but I landed in the the
team looking for Greg saw me oh man I
got absolutely destroyed I made a stupid
bonehead maneuver I let a guy like me I
killed his buddy Kevin get that in p7
maybe they forgot about you no one no
the one on the left here you saw the
pistol grip I don't like it
I had a [ __ ] one bolt goddamn
crossbow before that all right is that
guy though you get you got a great time
sure uh Eddie ticking
in the chest says oh my god Greg you're
not John direct it's okay don't do it
yeah you gotta play the first-person
shooter before I run away yeah just run
away yeah they want me to be there you
know how much money does he have any buy
ones back and also Cody Jake places
y'all should have these guys on home I
mean I know how hard it'd be for Lucy to
get in touch with Greg the guy just
killing use the other gun he's dead you
got him yeah no doubt
is he above you yeah there's if you cut
to the other guys scream and they're
just doing the exact same dance just one
floor up he won't even know it
doesn't rate Gregg for the enjoyment
back to the stream we should all just
get like die super quick just watch Greg
try to survive he got this guy he got
this guy I said go hard left hard left
hard left hard left little nice little
fake out of all they call you your
juggernaut oh my god three get him
ladies and gentlemen he cannot be
stopped the Gulag king you know to this
day every time since blog i always think
they're talking about some sort of soup
but they are not doing a goulash yeah
that's the one when then I start
thinking about vichyssoise and then I
think about Batman - great job yeah get
that Oh got King yeah stay alive we all
come back this the one where I got to
stay alive for three minutes yeah yeah
you can mean it's high-risk high-reward
right but like some would say I might
have a better shot alone doing it than
getting you have $0 yeah yes I miss it I
did not do that well don't listen to
change to cheeto fingers man alright he
wanted to land up there guys we're not
gonna sit here and say that he didn't
start it and then realize he totally
buffed it like right off the bat and it
was like aw man oh yes get that Bizon
and then replaced a pistol with there
was another one back there those a
better weapon back there just keep
getting silenced
Oh were there somebody on you coming
they're coming baby they're gonna be
straight ahead hide under the bed that's
not a bad play great Oh Oh God that's
not like it came from your left Greg
that guy came in like a wrecking ball
magic salmon says his Greg just found
his new favorite game he seems to be
better than the at this than hunting
ground look at that damn it's 1,400 I'm
starting to come around about you and
think that maybe you do belong in our
squad after all Andy I'm sorry you're
out
oh you sure I'm just trying to think
about the health of the squad and the
wins we could get I'm sorry exactly
we're doing MBA rules if you can't put
up the shots the points then you can't
just you don't deserve to be in the game
don't worry Michael Nelson $25 to black
lives matter
Ritchie bracket Monday $25 Jowita Kagami
$10 Teddy Haas $25 Chris drew $10 Matt
Hawking $10 thanks Matt he's been always
it tetchy
that's just how I would say it really
I've always been seeing techie but then
this is a touchy house I was like oh
maybe that's a reference to Naruto or
something oh maybe I never watched
Naruto I have no idea
so anything that references Ryan Joey
also gave 10 bucks to Direct Relief and
says Greg is kind of okay I guess thank
you I'll take it Thank You Joey oh it is
technique Chris gave $10 and says Greg
doesn't suck the heat him hurt $20 will
donate my firstborn
if Greg ever finishes persona 5 also I
guide in the division when I was typing
this so hashtag right sighs Greg doesn't
suck Greg suck as much Greg doesn't suck
I'll take it Joey is a too late for me
to vote
the gold patreon topic for today that
we're doing a four o'clock let me know
in the chat don't slack me oh we're
supposed to be doing that
thank you yes that's after PSL Evita um
never saw it I never will you want see
you don't see Greg coming man cuz Greg
is the silent king he is our silent yo
he's landing in a ball he really is
Greg which one do you like lightning in
a bottle or silent King where's the
light silent bottle King it's a moments
like this ladies gentlemen that was a
genuine reaction for Greg that I haven't
warned him not one here we talk anymore
she the thing is do you want like you're
getting in his head right now I need you
to shut up so where's Greg is in prime
form right now you're only a distraction
right now I'll accept this alright I
accept this
what the hell is this gun alright so
guys we got like 15 minutes left of the
stream so this is video this is the
final game which means that we have to
win me a night apparently I don't have
anything to do with this it's all Gregg
I'm gonna die whole damn ship I love
that uh cheeto fingers has played two
games there was it one or two I that was
my second game Andy the first one
remember was the one where Greg decided
that he did dead Lucy was reviving me I
was not dead and the last thing I saw as
I had acted with my as my eyes started
to just fade into the darkness with the
top of your head just disappearing over
the hill and you were running away from
us show us our new coward treachery oh
yeah we'll get 40 let's go back to
military base okay we're ten about Andy
it did not work out so well for it maybe
we got to pull the strategy if we start
on the outskirts and just slowly work
our way
we can't go too far because the ring is
not yeah but there's also a lot of recon
and stuff we can do over there Greg are
you you might be too low now you're fine
you're totally I got it doing Greg got
it doesn't have had me a while to get
over through a story he'll know we're
not dropping superstore dude coward
get a VEC Shem that's a nice-looking
hotel right there should we just drop
there and said there's only 15 people
converging on it right now man when you
get shot out of the sky
it is demoralizing it sure is Nick in
absolutely is and I feel like I say that
because it's about to happen I'm really
high up in the air right now and I feel
like I'm in that's gonna happen to me
yeah okay lot of peeps drop it they're
everywhere you guys maybe but you guys
want it landed here in Death Valley so
y'all let me find out guys this is not a
hot spot chill out looks like this is
one TV oh there's another guy there's no
guy behind you behind you behind you
behind you uh-oh
that was dangerous that was scary
yeah I think oh my god vanilla
this thing nope I don't want to buy
anything I don't have a money no we
don't have money all right where are we
at Andy I'm running your six there's
simply people over here yellow jumping
through now I know Greg's like where can
I hide
no no I'm picking up cool weapons ain't
armed red if you see any shout out yeah
I need something right here all right
let's let's move into this next little
compound another team was here but
they're down one person says I killed
that guy earlier actually I don't know
if they're here they may have pieced
down yeah I don't think that around here
oh I've got a recon drone I can send
that out but I think we should we can
hold on to it oh we're weird
don't a snipe I'm so bad oh he's only
he's on the tower I broke his armor up
there just jumped out let's go hunt this
guy yeah he's over here I got ya there's
a lot of guys over here there Oh Greg
I'm coming to you I'll come to you
Lowell strike Andy I'm with you yes Greg
come back and kind of make I'm I'm on my
way to the great blog of the sadness I
got I gotta get a migraine you got this
you got this god I work him God yeah get
back on here could be her stuff where
was he uh he's vanished out there he's
have you pops out again I'm gonna
Stephanie I'm working my way up the
right flank
oh [ __ ] another angle I did not see this
guy where'd he go where'd he go
Co Sam he must be shut the back man I
don't know where the Andy just died what
happened
yeah I'm gonna go log he's just he was
on top of a tent yeah how'd he get up
there well I mean I can't this no okay
Andy you've got this you are the master
of the Google am I the only one the
Gulag yeah
oh great so the other team got I don't
know what that guy is that killed you do
we kill him yeah Greg got him yeah we're
good if you if you win and drop back in
here we can progress is high easy one
end easy one easy Monday and you guys
have money too if I die you can bring me
back yeah we're gonna well maybe all
right I'm gonna win we should go to a
base station anyway so um I'm gonna mock
mmm let's go this one oh that's me might
be are we right under that by station
yeah oh good
Andy you gotta know about Oh sounds
spicy over here yeah I don't like that
at all
let's go to this door there's a knob
where I got killed last time
okay I'm dropping over here with you all
oh we got money man yeah we are rich
we're doing just fine okay
sorry let's buy a load up yeah everybody
give me your money drop your money for
me
get it get it always I am buying armor
and if I miss my armor right comeget
army come get your armor
thanks I am actually gonna swap that gun
back cuz that was nice okay do you all
have sniper ammo if you all open up
where you were dropping me money earlier
that there should be an awful up a tarp
again what am I looking for a first
library ammo
it's like the long bullet known you if
you right
oh I do i how do I get over to it okay I
gotta be my is this her air yeah and
there nailed it thank you there you go
someone in the chat assessed 1440 said I
wonder what Greg Nick and Andy would be
like if they were combined into one
person that's a great question I think
it'd be the most dominant force in
gaming think I know right yeah step
aside you bots we did that one person
would be the number one dot problem to
go to it's a one-person one-man show you
know just do anything should we go after
this other loadout back there it seems
kind of dangerous I'm kind of scared I
mean Andy you t there you go let's get
the yes
[Music]
oh there's an ammo here if you all need
to re get a bunch of ammo like I never
say I got man I've never driven the
helicopter so I'm just gonna
what do you see if it's your turn to go
where I am Nick look right okay oh no
wait
Oh fire say let's go back let's go back
shopping cart do you want me to bring
the helicopter yeah weird goods all
right now guys you're you are Most
Wanted Nick gotta you picked that thing
up I don't know bad market do nothing
everybody come to the bike everybody
come to buy station by self revive kit
so Greg if you get down you can hold the
e button and then bring yourself back up
to life okay it does everyone know or
not be button unit yeah well I'm sure
it'll be on the screen right it'll be I
do not have enough money for a self
revive kidding because I gave you all my
money
no no oh my god why - it's free right
gonna bite you tomorrow no okay
unfortunately so if I hit Most Wanted
what does that mean does that mean
everyone can see me um they kill me they
get extra points oh oh oh uh Lucy you
can come by a UAV there are 800 bucks
[ __ ] for the fire sale I'm on it
where are you asking ik I'm just was
asking about most one Melba's most
wanted so if I get that do I have to
talk like Jamie Kennedy exactly yep
that's it you have the froster tips
we're a little headband that makes them
so we have a minute and a half to go
Nick and if you survive we get hella
money cool well but but because your
most wanted everybody can see you on the
Maverick that was the question I was
asking that was so I'm just basically
doomed best like an idiot no I mean I
got one we got a minute
[Music]
oh god what is that Kevin stop calling
me Kevin the disc you're ruining this
stream with your discord call Kevin stop
calling me who's flying bad
I'm not fly hold on I want to switch
seats there we go Andy you fly I'm
coming to you I don't know how to fly
Greg you're the captain now
oh no oh yes sever flip not just sit in
one spot to be so okay check this out
there are lock-on rockets in this game
if you see lock-on just get out jump
okay but I have flares I could use
flares so you could we could Jeff it up
Rick
Jeff it up fuzzball stop calling me Oh
God you use the why'd you use them
Oh excite to use them so I used them
damn it need to use abuse them no you
say let me say chaff a dead fuzz bowling
I did it that that was what we were
deciding on the terminology but when I
saw something and you have to come
Chapin you said it twice so I had to do
it okay chop it again let's see what
that looks like I don't think you can
high IQ stress you got a we got this
guys I'm glad I got that Malibu's Most
Wanted let's let's go down to the alkali
lake down there and see if Wolverines
still hanging out well that's all
dropped on top of there
Oh get on that building yeah that worth
gonna be or or we drop on top of the
airport name all right Greg you wanna
run this building walls just take a pill
take an old PC see you know what I mean
see what so nobody can nobody can get on
top of this building what's your eye
state land the helicopter on top of that
boy ban we just wait just wait that's
what I'm saying you got nothing else to
do for the rest today I have no more
shows to do how do you Greg
well no they were calling me to do the
show after due to [ __ ] that you can
watch on patreon.com Oh God
Thank You Connie
oh yeah for sure we're fine we're told
well you weren't the one getting shot
the guy shot me three times I don't have
any teeth left
how am I supposed to eat now Frank I
don't know where they are shooting from
you're kind of looking at my Drive sure
yeah oh yeah we're oh yeah that little
ladder it's locked I don't see if they
can't get up here so long as we don't
see another helicopter coming if we do
have to just destroy it
and make sure they don't like oh you
know the weird part of tik-tok that I'm
in right now is people getting double
jewel surgery
before and afters what does that mean
surgery me like I've got an underbite
and they get it they get it fixed but
like you have to break your jaw and get
braces oh oh oh that sounds horrible
just use the under bite man who cares
like Slingblade the fraud dangers
thank you Greg the one fret and he's
like what that's a sling though I know
it's thing but my parents loved that
movie
maybe is terrifying in slingbow so we're
doing a Gwen Stefani blade crossover
joke it's impossible without it being
completely insensitive we should also
throw some banger this is my left foot
in there just helicopter up here
helicopter oh yeah they're getting shot
at on top from some way oh they're
getting shot from like over here on
yellow
I'm not hitting with it all Oh are they
come in dude they're coming baby
Oh
this is the local AG ever I'm just gonna
waste my ammo not smart oh are they
going down just cut me they just they
want our position guys I told you this
real estate was good we were holding
this rooftop oh no my whirlybird no no
they shot it this sons of [ __ ]
where'd they go where'd they go they got
the clue way they they were they had the
worst connection possible helicopter was
a shift in left and right
that's I'll go with that narrative sure
that's why I couldn't hit him someone
how're you doing over there but I zone
if he landed on the roof or not but I
need ammo guys this is really bad I have
like not a whole lot of a r-mo times are
tough couldn't get the bird Greg I'm
sorry about your helicopter it's sucks
man I was sitting there but at least you
know only she went down we'll miss
Alicia but we won't you know we live on
without her we can't we can't
specifically cuz we're on here but I
will say this if you fall off this roof
you are dead you are a dead human being
yeah yeah what's this beam of golden
light to the South Mossad who is firing
here someone's kiss I'm gonna snap him
is [ __ ] out of me guys over here then oh
yeah oh wait I downed a guy up there
Andy are you on that tower yeah I see PC
I'm okay
guess what we're top 20 with top 15 oh
yeah we are gonna get the pop man little
fingers and natural this is how it goes
I want the helicopter should we go get
it no we can't they're looking at us
careful they have snipers careful with
that tower with the beer screwed guys
we're fine we're at a great place we're
in the middle of the bubble they have to
get they're gonna the Flies are here
they're gonna send murderous they're
gonna land on this we're gonna take them
out before they even hit the ground
everyone reload lycopene is rhiarna we
armor it says if I hit l1 and r1 I get a
mask what does that mean what does that
no no it's like I'm gonna rob a
convenience store mask oh they're gonna
come on Oh dead silence yeah so that
means that you don't make footstep
sounds Greg you move a lot faster as
well and it's limited time I said yeah
it's a little limited time thing okay I
have the same thing that's cool well
when they land I'll do it so they can't
hear me coming
sounds good I haven't V and a drone if
we can bomb them right now that'd be
amazing
we're being hunted
so you see Nick your name on the Left
wheel one threat yeah they're close the
more red that gets Greg yeah that means
that they are right on us that are
probably right below us or something
helicopter battle behind us it looks
like and now there's a helicopter yep oh
god oh god that guy's dead that guy is
smoky and he is dead thank God good oh
yeah fly the drone was it drone
aiming me where i flying it to oh
actually don't wait it's but it's it's a
moot point they have to come back yeah
this team is gonna be dropping on us
need something you in the tower I I
think I'm how much AR ammo do you all
have I have volts 121 total Oh 210 150 I
go because I have 70 okay oh sorry take
I'll get back to you on who needs it me
I dropped that for Andy where what is it
what could happen you picked up in front
of me
they are yeah yeah I needed it I realize
I'll give you some anything I'll give
you something I have 70 total Oh make it
you're more important than you take it
along what is happening those are those
are drops that you pick up so it's okay
so the guys on the tower pieced out
where they go they're below us now they
didn't fly over here I mean can anyone
say goodbye to us I hear I think we just
stay up here and then whoever dies dies
yeah there's people in the smoke where
there's smoke okay well I'll just close
man we were gonna get top ten right here
baby
don't jinx it this is the spot the only
way we die is if someone continent
airstrike on us yeah but even then what
yes we should just spread out just
spread out I'll go to the other side of
the roof and just wait it's good point
there's no way the air drops gonna take
this whole without although it puts me
far away from you guys if you get in
trouble
the password is pickle just scream
pickle would you see we're going to jump
where's that oh Christ we gotta go all
the way over there yeah good people
dropping there yeah this is gonna be a
nightmare but hey we got top ten already
yeah let's drop at the end of parking
lot okay but wait till I mean I want to
wait to that gas is on us yeah wait till
wicked war we can't barely breathe
here we go you seem they're right below
us they're gonna be all underneath we
making for that little spot what are we
making for ya then we're gonna be
Atlanta on yellow on top of the right at
the edge of the parking rocket and we
have a safe spot okay they are they in
front of that are they behind it they're
underneath it they're underneath us
right now yeah
got it so we're gonna try to flank that
parking lot right there I just want to
get on top of the bargain lund got on
top of the parking lot though
Oh more ammo hell yeah yeah they are
they are underneath those keep that in
mind
hey more cash cool we buy stuff man well
we're gonna have to jump down cuz the
circle is gonna be yeah we're on the
edge of it yeah here make sure you don't
get trapped
make sure you - oh behind it down
together smoke okay are we jumping yeah
we got a jump oh yeah then for the best
oh we're safe here yeah please pay fair
be safe we're gonna have to push for
anything yeah I can't he keeps popping
his head out I'm right on top of Greg
right now
glass I hate when it comes like this
look I can still get by by you I don't
know if you come on top of that HAARP
site duh damn it I'm down down to the
guy to the left
got your left everyone's left I'm coming
off this little Tarkin someone save me
yeah if you come down and get you just
fall this fall to fall oh [ __ ] here
there
okay team one driving here I'm here I'm
here
I got this guy that was peeking over I'm
running in here yeah okay we just know
there's one dude there's multiple things
that are way over there they're about to
cross yeah it's like going down they're
coming to us stick together
where's Andy I'm gonna go I'm Greg come
on Esther there's a guy like over here
on yellow where I just think oh god
there's a dude on a roof over that oh
he's getting shot I do come across the
way we come to you Greg come again are
you
dad door you know i'm already inspected
okay listen do you doubt that guys have
requested okay
yeah they're all there's five guys back
there okay everybody armor well close
thanks for having us loose yeah games
[Music]
with me Ron Contreras not Hawking again
and else we got our Ville Adam hood
Chris thank you so much everyone for
donating and shooting in thank you guys
thanks for watching thank you loopy ye
subscriber funny
you